herr lindner wenn sie denn verhindern
könnten dass es eine deutsche regierung
gibt in der die linkspartei sitzt würden
sie das tun das ist ja die frage an sie
gerade sie haben damals den bruch von
jamaika begründet damit dass sie einen
linksruck befürchteten und jetzt könnte
man ja einen linksruck vermeiden nicht
indem man nicht regiert sondern indem
man regiert sie könnten ja sagen ich bin
bereit zu verhindern dass eine
linkspartei an die macht kommen
verhinderung allein das wäre ein zu
bescheidener anspruch an gestaltung und
das heißt sie wollen nicht sagen dass
sie eine ampel eigentlich eine tolle
lösung finden sie ist jetzt realistisch
sie hat eine rechnerische mehrheit sowie
aus jamaika oder eine deutschland
koalition so viel ist richtig aber
dennoch muss man doch über inhalte
sprechen
wir haben einen inhaltlichen anspruch an
politik wir sind nicht eine abgeleitete
größe etwa der cdu csu wir regieren in
einem jamaika bündnis in
schleswig-holstein wir regieren schwarz
gelb in nordrhein westfalen
wir regieren in einer übrigens
bestätigten ampel in rheinland pfalz und
wir regieren in einer neuen deutschland
koalition in sachsen anhalt von allen
sozialdemokraten müsste ihnen olaf
scholz doch eigentlich der sympathisch
zu sein der hat die schwarze null
durchgehalten von wolfgang schäuble der
hat andere dinge gemacht die nicht also
gelesen aber ich lese aber das programm
und ich kenne auch saskia esken zu und
deshalb sage ich wenn ich die programme
nebeneinander legen fehlt mir noch die
fantasie welches angebot herr scholz zum
beispiel der fdp machen könnte das für
uns attraktiv wäre und nicht frau
kollegin esken oder kevin kühnert sagen
würden nicht mit uns vor es denn sie
sind dabei uns zu erklären warum
eigentlich nicht mit der linkspartei sie
könnten die höheren löhne durchsetzen
sie könnten höhere
die entschuldigung dafür sorgen dass die
mieten sinken sie könnten sich von den
hartz reformen verabschieden sie könnten
andere dinge mehr auch das enteignen man
müsste eben nur aushalten dass die
kollegen von der linkspartei ein anderes
verhältnis zur nato haben warum
eigentlich nicht mit denen also was wir
vorhaben und was wir wollen das haben
wir schon sehr früh aufgeschrieben und
anders als jetzt er interpretiert wird
ist es nicht im programm des einzelnen
parteivorsitzenden mit einzelnen
stellvertretern zusammen geschrieben
haben sondern unser präsidium
erweitert durch wichtige personen aus
der regierung insbesondere olaf scholz
der ja schon sehr lange unser
kanzlerkandidat ist haben gemeinsam ein
programm auf geschrieben dessen was wir
der auffassung sind was notwendig ist
für die zwanziger jahre dieses
jahrhunderts um deutschland auch in eine
gute zukunft zu führen und das haben wir
uns jetzt gemeinsam vorgenommen wir
werden sehen mit wem wir da die meisten
übereinstimmungen haben um tatsächlich
auch viel von diesem programm gutes für
das land zu tun und die gespräche werden
wir uns begeben und da kann ich auch
heute abend gar nicht mehr dazu sagen
niemals zu sagen was sie ab hirte mit
der linkspartei zusammen zu gehen sie
haben gesagt dass sie diese option nicht
mehr ausschließen wollen dieses
schreckliche wort von der
ausschließeritis machte damals die runde
was müsste die linkspartei den liefern
damit sie mit ihr zusammen gehen und
dann reden wir über innere haben wir
haben damals 2013 klaren beschluss
gefasst in der spd bei dem
bundesparteitag und der hat sich nicht
alleine auf die linkspartei bezogen
sondern der war ganz klar wir koalieren
nicht und wir arbeiten nicht zusammen
mit rechtsradikalen das ist ohnehin
glaube ich fast eine
selbstverständlichkeit unter
demokratischen parteien auch wenn teile
der cdu manchmal da die klarheit
vermissen lassen aber wir haben auch
ganz klar gesagt dass es um solide
haushaltspolitik geht und das ist vor
allem um stabile ein stabiles verhältnis
zum zum zum transatlantischen
zusammenarbeit geht das ist um ein
klares bekenntnis zur nato geht und der
starken oder nicht zu einer starken
europäischen union mit welcher
linksparteien mit welchem partner
personal wie es nach der wahl zu tun
haben inhaltlich bei der linkspartei ist
ja die frage das kann man ja heute hat
man ja erst letzte woche bei der
abstimmung im bundestag sehen können
dass da keine regierungsfähigkeit in
keine regierung ist auch
kein wille da ist eine
regierungsbeteiligung und wir werden
aber nach der wahl sehen
das ist haben wir einen klaren beschluss
dazu dass wir nicht vor der wahl uns
festlegen in der frage mit wem sprechen
wir nach der wahl sondern das werden wir
nach der wahl tun und ohnehin ist heute
noch nicht klar wir haben heute gute
zustimmungswerte wir freuen uns über
diese guten zustimmungswerte sowohl für
olaf schulz als auch für uns und für
unsere programmatik aber wahlergebnisse
stehen am wahlabend fest wie und damit
gibt es keine antwort wie auch von olaf
scholz nicht gerade noch mal ganz
schnell die man eigentlich einmal fragen
frau es gibt warum warum verweigern sie
dem wähler diese klarheit den beschluss
verstehe ich aber haben die leute nicht
ein anrecht darauf dass die leute sorgen
und fragen ob die partei das vielleicht
frage ich gleich haben mich schon
dreimal ob es vielleicht taktische
gründe sind die das olaf scholz und
seine freunde und genossen so handhaben
lassen kann es einen praktischen grund
geben das taktischen grund geben aber
ich sage in einer demokratie wäre
eigentlich sozusagen klarheit und
wahrheit kann man doch nicht die ganze
zeit postulieren
steht in unserem programm dort steht
drin was wir uns vorgenommen haben und
damit werben wir jetzt für mir halten
also es ist ja schon so dass es schon
das wahlprogramm der spd wird nicht eins
zu eins umgesetzt werden und natürlich
wird das was die spd in der regierung
macht sehr stark davon geprägt sein mit
wem sie koaliert also welche teile des
wahlprogramms dann wirklich wahr werden
und in welcher ausprägung wird natürlich
anders sein ob das jetzt in der ampel
ist oder in der großen koalition die ja
keiner mehr will oder eben in einem
linksbündnis insofern ist da natürlich
was daran dass man kann das wahlprogramm
lesen aber um sich im hinterkopf schon
mal ein häkchen zu machen wie es denn
dann am ende ausgeht ist es natürlich
interessant zu wissen wie die
konzentration ist aber wegen ihrer frage
nach der taktik ich meine dass wicke auf
der hand also wenn olaf scholz kanzler
werden will dann kann er das eigentlich
nur in zwei konstellationen realistisch
entweder in einer ampel oder in einem
rot grün roten bündnis und wenn er eins
von beiden ausschließt ja dann kann herr
lindner hat er ja sozusagen alle trümpfe
in der hand für ein ampelbündnis
ansonsten hat herr scholz ja sozusagen
gar keine möglichkeit zu sagen ja gut
das gefällt mir aber nicht dann mache
ich seit mit den anderen und insofern
ist da natürlich auch ein taktisches
endras ist ja jetzt noch mal eine frage
oder scholz ginge wenn dann nur als
kanzler fresken und er ginge nicht als
vizekanzler
norbert weiter bei uns hat gesagt
entweder 74 oder opposition sagen sie
dass auch unser ziel ist jetzt ganz klar
dass olaf schulz bundeskanzler wird und
unser ziel ist auch ganz klar dass diese
nächste regierung weil sie fragen nach
von wem die geprägt sein wird dass die
von der spd geprägt sein wird und
deswegen ist schon sehr entscheidend zu
lesen dass wir uns vor gesucht und dann
interessiert den wählern natürlich
trotzdem wie sehr es auch von der
linkspartei geprägt sein wird dieses
bündnis noch mal die ganz persönliche
frage an sie sie sind auch wähler und
sie sind auch bürger dieses landes
denken sie es wäre eine zumutung für die
menschen zu erfahren ob olaf scholz mit
der linkspartei zusammengehen also auch
in vergangenen wahlen hat die spd nicht
vorher gesagt wir wollen gerne in eine
große koalition gehen oder wir wollen
wir streben eine sozialliberale
koalition oder
rot grün ist unsere lieblings
konstellationen sind sie hat für eigene
stärke dabei werden wir auch gleiche
aber trotzdem gab es schon konstellation
ich erinnere mich zum beispiel dass olaf
scholz der jetzt so oft gerne über
sozial liberal spricht vor wenigen
jahren in hamburg vor einer
bürgerschaftswahl
obwohl es eine schwarz eine sozial
liberale mehrheit hätte geben können
noch vor der wahl jedes gespräch mit der
fdp ausgeschlossen hat und er hat sich
vor der wahl exklusiv auf die grünen
festgelegt also insofern es gibt in der
spd schon vor der wahl gelegentlich
klarheit in dem fall in hamburg war es
ausschluss fdp ausschluss sozialliberal
exklusiv grün deshalb muss man sehr
ernst nehmen wenn die spd vor dieser
wahl die linkspartei nicht ausschließt
und tatsächlich wenn man die programme
nebeneinander liegt von spd grünen und
linkspartei
sieht man ein inhaltliches
verwandtschaftsverhältnis nicht im
bereich der außenpolitik haben sie
völlig recht würde ich niemals infrage
stellen dass die spd da verlässlich beim
transatlantischen bündnis und mit blick
auf europa ist es völlig klar
unterscheiden sie sich von der
linkspartei das wäre nicht seriös ihnen
anderes zu unterstellen aber in der
steuerpolitik weil der frage wie man im
miteigentum umgeht da gibt es schon mehr
ich wollte einmal nur sagen dass olaf
scholz auch ihnen eben nicht nur
komplimente macht er nicht nur sondern
sogar versucht sie zu verstehen in bezug
auf die letzten verhandlungen als es um
jamaika ging ganz kurz hören nach meinem
eindruck haben union und grüne damals zu
zweit verhandelt und gedacht die fdp
brauche nur noch zu unterschreiben das
war nicht klug und kein ausweis
besonderer regierungskunst
das ist doch aber irgendwie mal eine
nette geste damit sagt er im grunde auch
das würde er so nicht noch mal tun würde
er ihnen so nicht noch mal antun das ist
mehr als nur ein kompliment würde ich
sagen das riecht schon nach das sehe ich
nicht als ein kompliment sondern die
beschreibung von den scholz ist richtig
man hat solche beschreibungen auch von
herrn dobrindt schon gehört dass er hat
sich inzwischen auch bei vielen jahr
gezeigt die fdp war nur als mehr als
beschaffer aber nicht als ideengeber
geplant 2017 und ich finde jede partei
hat ihre identität und hat ihre projekt
das muss man auch achten jeder teil
einer koalition muss eine chance haben
sich auch ein zu bringen dann muss man
sich in bestimmten dingen zurücknehmen
und bei anderen fragen hat man eben
seinen erfolg das war seinerzeit nicht
geplant und herr scholz sagt er will es
anders angehen übrigens herr laschet
macht das in der ständigen staatspraxis
in nordrhein westfalen zwischen union
und fdp genau so und so verstehe ich
auch koalition wenn man gemeinsam erfolg
haben will muss auch jeder teil einer
koalition und seine nachfolger haben
gewinnen können und natürlich eben auch
inhaltlicher bestandteil sei letzte
frage gabor steingart zu diesen
koalitions
rothmann oder arbeiten muss man ja sagen
erklär uns einer was die union jetzt
macht markus söder sagt eine ampel wäre
tatsächlich auch ein linksrutsch wenn
auch ein verdienter linksrutsch und herz
ihm sagt der generalsekretär der cdu
sagte wer die fdp wählt kann mit den
grünen und mit der spd aufwachen also da
versucht sich jetzt plötzlich die union
an der fdp auch abzuarbeiten
aber
da muss man doch verständnis haben
knappe niederlage ja ich finde dasselbe
was ich zuvor schon gesagt hat gilt auch
für die union die muss man sagen wofür
sie eigentlich regieren will mit wem das
ist interessante frage und was man gegen
die anderen hat es auch das ist
sozusagen handwerkszeug rote socken wie
auch immer aber ich will doch wissen als
wähler und und das land hat ein anrecht
darauf dass jemand sagt wofür er
eigentlich steht was mit armin laschet
denn er macht ja in wahrheit auch die
raute wir sind beide rauten eigentlich
zu wenig nach 16 jahren 16 jahren die im
übrigen einen relativen abstieg
deutschlands gebracht relativ zu den
anderen großen wirtschaftsmächten und
auch die vermögensposition der kleinen
leute weil es ging hat sich eben nicht
verbessert sich das prekariat ist
entstanden der niedriglohnsektor und so
weiter ich verstehe auch dass mieten
thema da sind dinge ganz schief auf die
schiefe bahn geraten in deutschland und
die gründe muss man besprechen den ball
kam und dann muss einer sagen wie will
ich es abschalten will ich enteignen
oder will ich mehr wohnungsbau zum
beispiel wäre ja auch eine alternative
zu hohen mieten vielleicht stimmt ja mit
der marktwirtschaft zu ordnen und fangen
mit den steuern an und da macht
ausgerechnet die fdp einen granaten
vorschlag nämlich sie möchte die steuern
senken
christian lindners zentrales
wahlversprechen schulden runter und
gleichzeitig steuern senken dabei klafft
in den kommenden haushalten schon jetzt
ein loch von knapp 40 milliarden euro zu
der bundesrechnungshof auch wegen der
korona hilfen sind die kassen leer
die steuersenkungspläne der fdp würden
insgesamt fast 90 milliarden euro kosten
rechnet das leibniz institut vor
christian lindner das wahlversprechen am
ende gar nicht finanzierbar
das ist jetzt interessant herr lindner
haben sie irgendwo im geheimen
geldspeicher oder so also zb ein
institut leibniz institut
bundesrechnungshof rechnet vor was die
nächsten drei haushalte irgendwie allein
an
bedarfsgerechte
und ein finanzminister der nicht so
richtig weiß was in der kasse ist jetzt
auch nicht erst qualität so
wir haben uns alles nicht wir haben zwei
leitplanken die erste leitplanke ist wir
sind ein höchst steuer land nur belgien
hat noch eine ähnliche belastung wie
deutschland selbst mit einem
geringeren einkommen bezahlt man über
das jahr schon mehr als 50 prozent an
steuern und abgaben deshalb sehe ich
keine möglichkeit die steuern in
deutschland zu erhöhen wenn man private
investitionen in den klimaschutz will
wenn die menschen wieder reserven
aufbauen sollen die betriebe wieder
eigenkapital aufbauen sollen um für die
nächste krise gewappnet zu sein und im
übrigen ist es für den facharbeiter und
die angestellte heute doch überhaupt gar
nicht mehr möglich
am ende des berufslebens ein abbezahlt
fürs eigenheim eine wohnung zu haben
deshalb sehe ich keine möglichkeit die
steuern zu erhöhen deshalb ist das
unsere erste leitplanke keine höheren
steuern es gibt eine zweite leitplanke
wir haben inflationsrisiken
wegen der pandemie und der
unterbrochenen lieferketten fraglos aber
sicherlich auch wegen der enormen
verschuldung in europa und unserer
notenbankpolitik und deshalb empfiehlt
es sich nicht in deutschland jetzt die
erkenntnis dass der staat nicht auf
dauer mehr geld ausgeben kann als er
einnimmt diese erkenntnis zu verletzen
und dazwischen
da findet dann aushandlung stadt unsere
vorschläge für steuerentlastung sind
jedenfalls nicht geplant in einem
haushaltsjahr gar umgesetzt zu werden
sondern die müssen eine reihenfolge
gebracht werden ich glaube ein erster
schritt müsste sein dass wir die
investitionen in anlagen also die
investitionen in technik für
digitalisierung und klimaschutz dass wir
die steuerlich beschleunigen damit wir
aus der krise heraus wachsen damit jobs
entstehen und sich heute zweifeln selbst
institute dass das gelingen kleinen aus
dieser krise heraus was tun sie nicht
freuen ganz im gegenteil sie sagen es
wird auf jeden fall nicht so schnell
nein dann können die zuschauerinnen und
zuschauer beispielsweise den ifo
schnelldienst vom 23 ganz klar das lesen
ja relativ klar in unsere richtung
argumentieren die sache nochmal diese
studien die sie zitiert haben einen
nachteil die errechnen nämlich alle
vorschläge und sie errechnen sie und
auch und zeitgleich und auf ein
haushaltsjahr und in der regel wird der
effekt nicht berücksichtigt dass durch
gezielte entlastung iv gutachten da sie
dadurch auch die wirtschaftliche
belebung steigt und das 1 2 milliarden
sind trotzdem ein bisschen fehl und mein
name zahl stimmt die zahl stimmt auch
nein sie ist zu hoch beispielsweise es
in der zahl enthalten der
solidaritätszuschlag
der solidaritätszuschlag ist aber
verfassungswidrig selbst der
bundesrechnungshof hat ihre bedenken
angemeldet olaf scholz hätte
seriöserweise niemals den
solidaritätszuschlag weiter in die
einnahme planung des staates aufnehmen
dürfen gut da ist ein klagen klagen
versucht worden bisher hat der
bundesrechnungshof hat das
bundesverfassungsgericht noch nicht
recht gegeben es ist zwei mal der
versuch gestartet worden hatte geurteilt
ein drittes urteil und ihr habt noch
nicht beurteilt in dieser sache richtig
es ist das höchste deutsche gericht wir
sind bei der frage voraus bach ist es
gut jetzt steuern zu senken in dieser
situation dieses angebot zu machen ist
es nachvollziehbar oder schließen sich
sie sich der kritik an die die man
gemeinhin liest an den steuerplänen der
fdp
also die fdp will ja an verschiedenen
stellen ansetzen unter anderem soll
diese berühmte mittelstandsbauch in der
einkommensteuer
abgeflacht oder abgeschafft werden durch
linearen tarif das ist aber wirklich
extrem teuer also das ist etwas was man
wirklich ist muss man begrüßen natürlich
ist der einkommenssteuertarif wie wir
ihn haben
leistungsfeindlich und trifft vor allem
eben mittlere einkommen ihnen aber
wirklich komplett zu begradigen ist sehr
teuer es wäre projekt aber das wird sich
nicht in wirklich sehr kurzen
zeitfenstern realisieren lassen
bei der unternehmensteuer ist schon
richtig dass man auf den internet die
internationale wettbewerbsfähigkeit
schauen muss der unternehmen und das da
vermutlich eine steuerreform irgendwann
mal an steht ob sie jetzt direkt
realisiert werden kann am anfang das ist
fraglich natürlich ist es so dass es die
industrie das ist die wirtschaft belebt
wenn unternehmen weniger steuern zahlen
müssen aber dieser trickle down effekt
also dass sich das quasi alles nicht nur
selbst finanziert sondern daneben
sozusagen noch eine positive rendite
abwirft das
erhalten glaube ich sehr viele ökonomen
inzwischen auch nicht mehr so gegeben
das problem ist natürlich auch dass auf
der anderen seite diese gigantischen
investitionen anstehen um eben die
transformation hin zu einer co2
neutralen wirtschaft zu schaffen und
natürlich müssen wir müssen die
allermeisten dieser investition aus der
privatwirtschaft kommen das ist schon
klar aber die frage ist ob sie das
wirklich alleine schaffen können diese
summe aufzubringen wenn man gleichzeitig
eben nicht sozusagen die spielräume zur
schuldenaufnahme
erweitert jetzt haben sie schon merken
sie selber ist ein bisschen klein
bisschen widersprochen weil sie sagen
sind sollen private investitionen sollen
gleichzeitig soll der staat sich
verschulden ich glaube es nicht reichen
wird zu sagen wir erreichen dass 1,5
grad ziel alleine durch eine co2
bepreisung und durch den emissionshandel
und in ihrem programm steht wörtlich
drin den weg dorthin überlassen wir den
deutschen ingenieuren der in der bdi der
dgb die gehen von ich glaube 450
milliarden für 10 jahre aus ich bin
nicht sicher dass die wirtschaft das
quasi komplett alleine stemmen kann
irgendwann wird sie sagen ja sie wollen
dass das dass das emissions- caps zu
sagen so stark senken sind jetzt gerade
jetzt wir sind noch bei der steuer sie
sind schon beim beim klimaschutz will
wir müssen glaube ich beides voneinander
lösen
radio
investierte summe für den aber das
meiste was wir an investitionen leisten
müssen ist ja im privaten bereich
stromnetz der wiener ordner zu den
steuerlich axt das sind alles jahr
private investoren ich will noch mal nur
auf den punkt hinaus und ich glaube dass
sogar vielleicht manche aufgeklärten
sozialdemokratischen
wirtschaftspolitiker dem gedanken näher
treten können wir haben jetzt die
aufgabe
aus der wirtschaftskrise erneut hinaus
wachstum zu erzeugen das haben wir nicht
andere volkswirtschaften sind sehr viel
schneller bei der erholung als wir es
hat eine reihe von gründen ein grund ist
dass wir gegenwärtig eine private
investitionszurückhaltung haben und
jetzt übrigens der der vorschlag den ich
gerade gemacht habe der beginn sollte
sein 1 ich nenne mal das wort super
abschreibungs programm um es zu
unterscheiden von sonderabschreibungen
und sie sind meine zeugen
abschreibungen sind für den staat
aufkommensneutral das heißt die kosten
nicht sie sind nur auf die zeit eine
verschiebung wir könnten dadurch aber
unser wachstum anregen jobs schaffen
private investitionen zum beispiel in
den klimaschutz trainieren und damit
könnten wir eine belebung erreichen
durch die dem staat auch noch das
könnte fast denken sie sei dabei gewesen
als wir den wunsch zusammen aufgebaut
haben diese 130 milliarden euro rechnete
er nicht genau welche aber um so
schlecht steht unsere wirtschaft da ist
es so das sehe ich nicht ich sehe sehr
wohl dass wir arbeitsplätze erhalten
haben durch die kurzarbeit aber wir
haben auch die konjunktur stark auch
lena fauch durch investition ich schaue
nach vorne aber wir haben durchaus auch
schon zukunft investiere investitionen
angestoßen welche von des staates in auf
den weg gebracht und welche angestoßen
da sind steuerliche
abschreibungsmöglichkeiten verändert
worden und vieles neu getan worden um
die wirtschaft und dennoch ich komme
gleich nochmal darauf vss denn begonnen
haben wir ja mit allen gegen einer
solchen situation ist es ja wieder in
einer solchen situation die steuern
erhöhen
dazu erstmal muss man ja davon sprechen
den müll will ich haben durchaus recht
geben dass die kleinen und mittleren
einkommen dringend entlastet werden
müssen bei der steuer und das ist ja
auch teil des steuerkonzepts der spd die
die 95 prozent der einkommen bei der
steuer zu entlasten aber sagen wir mal
einkommen in der höhe wie sie herr
lindner und ich die haben die können
durchaus mehr beitragen zum gemeinwesen
dieses staates und wenn wir in die
bildung investieren wollen wenn wir in
modernen staat investieren wollen also
in digitale verwaltung und den vieles
andere mehr dann wird es wohl notwendig
sein dass der staat auch
handlungsfähigkeit bleibt und da sind
steuerentlastungen in dem maße wie sie
sie vorschlagen wie übrigens auch die
cdu/csu sie ja vorschlägt man ist sich
nicht ganz darüber im klaren ob jetzt
herr söder oder er herr laschet daneben
die richtung vorgibt aber es ist schon
ein bisschen in richtung voodoo und
herrlich gesetz vs kind ist jetzt
interessant wenn man jetzt wirklich
christian lindner aufmerksam zugehört
hat dann hat man zwei einlassungen
gemerkt einmal war klar dass es
investitionen braucht und viele
investitionen und er hat jüngst im
handelsblatt auch den vorschlag gemacht
oder gesagt dass man dafür in einer
übergangsphase sicherlich auch mehr
schulden braucht das heißt da ist die
bereitschaft der fdp auch eine tür zur
spd zu öffnen wenn man es so lesen wäre
eine schwarze null also eine schwarze
null obwohl sie auch damit zitiert
werden im handelsblatt aber egal und es
ist ein interessanter vorschlag zu sagen
lassen sie uns den unternehmen
abschreibungen ermöglichen eben nicht
als eine steuersenkung oder eine
klassische steuererhöhungen sondern eine
abschreibung ermöglichen das ist ein
echtes entgegenkommen warum das ist kein
entgegenkommen dass
ich geld habe
eine idee ich habe ja gesagt dass wir
auch schon damit agiert haben im verlauf
jetzt der der verein oder zu ende
gehenden legislatur tatsächlich muss man
aber sagen dass das die die steuer die
höhe der steuer der unternehmenssteuern
nicht die investitionen in deutschland
bremst das muss man ja gern ganz ehrlich
sagen da liegt eine menge geld auf der
hohen kante und es wird nicht investiert
diese diese investitionszurückhaltung in
der deutschen industrie in der deutschen
wirtschaft hat damit zu tun dass keine
klarheit herrscht wohin es eigentlich
geht exakt da ständigen jetzt ja sagen
deswegen müssen wir deswegen haben wir
auch ganz klar machen dass wir im
klimaschutz keinen keinen hin und her
machen kann bremsen wir haben können
sondern wir müssen jetzt wirklich auch
voranschreiten dann wird auch investiert
bin als wir haben ja in der
automobilindustrie in der frage eben
elektromobilität klare
vorgaben gemacht also dass in den
vergangenen monaten ihr deswegen sind
auch entscheidungen getroffen worden
lägen es quasi was sie vor dem zweiten
tag gesagt haben unterstütze ich es gibt
eine zurückhaltung bei investitionen
weil der weg nicht klar ist ich füge
noch hinzu wir haben in deutschland eine
bürokratisierung von planungs und
genehmigungsverfahren das selbst dann
wenn private initiative und privates
kapital da ist das gar nicht genutzt
werden kann und deshalb muss eine der
wesentlichen voraussetzungen für eine
wirtschaftliche belebung auch schon die
umstellung die entbürokratisierung sein
das sagen aber nicht nur
sozialdemokraten und freidemokraten das
sagen selbst grüne und christdemokraten
deshalb meine hoffnung wächst dass wir
einen punkt kommen wo wir gemeinsam
erkennen dass die
selbstverbuchung kratie sierung unseres
gemeinwesens beendet werden sind bei den
schulden gewesen gesteigert noch einmal
die frage schulden schulden machen in
dieser zeit das geld ist billig es ist
viel zu investieren
es ist die situation in deutschland
keine besonders gute und es gibt viele
die sagen in dieser zeit wo wir quasi
negativzinsen haben sich nicht zu
verschulden für diese investitionen die
wir brauchen ist unklug was sagen sie ja
ich sag ja das ist richtig aber jetzt
kommt das aber ich will mal ein wort
hier einführen das in der debatte noch
keine rolle gespielt hat marktwirtschaft
der markt das geld von dem wir reden für
klima und für die unternehmen das muss
am markt am kapitalmarkt und der
wirtschaft bereitstellen weil genau wie
sie sagen der ist geflutet da gibt es
viel geld das ist unterwegs das erwartet
gar nicht viel das kriegt nur
negativzinsen bei der deutschen bank und
bei der commerzbank dieses kapital
braucht gar nicht viel wir müssen dieses
kapital aktivieren und hier liegt eben
auch ein denkfehler wenn ich das sagen
darf was gehen die unterscheidung
zwischen den hohen einkommen und den
geringen einkommen ich finde schon mal
richtig die kleinen müssen entlastet
werden in der mitte hat einen kahlschlag
stattgefunden in den letzten 16 jahren
die leute können nicht vorsorgen aber
jetzt die oberen einkommen was machen
die leute die sitzen ja nicht auf dem
geld sondern es gibt ja gar nichts bei
der bank deswegen die haben auch nichts
auf der hohen kante in dem sinne wer
halbwegs clever ist der investiert
dieses geld und wir müssen diese
menschen aktivieren das geld zu
aktivieren oder in startups also selber
aktiv zu werden mit ihrem geld oder dem
der eltern dem der erbschaft oder eben
in aktien und wertpapiere in deutsche
firmen zu investieren wenn es geht
europäische firmen zu investieren dieses
geld muss aktiviert werden ohne diese
aktivierung gehen wir nun die
staatsverschuldung deswegen schulden ja
aber nicht der staat der staat hat der
ist bis über die halskrause voll und in
italien und anderswo sozusagen über der
halskrause müssen also irgendwie
solidität und wenn auch markus
krause voll entschuldigungen sind es
sind zum beispiel unsere schulen nicht
und sind ist auch etliche verwaltung
nicht ist unser gesundheitswesen nicht
mehr machen brauchen den dringenden
modernisierung sind überall dort ja und
das muss sehr stark machen wohl kaum
fried die mittel aber das ist allein
kugel unter krise war doch das problem
nicht sozusagen das kein geld vorhanden
ist wir blicken haben ein jahrzehnt
sprudelnder steuereinnahmen
zurück das problem ist einfach nur das
zum einen eben nicht die leitplanken so
gesetzt werden dass die der private
bereich die sicherheit hatte investieren
in diese und jene bereiche lohnt sich
weil ich sicher sein kann dass es so
kommt und weil natürlich der staat seine
einnahmen konsum tief verwendet hat
statt investiv und da waren sie nun mal
vorne mit dabei sie haben vielleicht
nicht die kanzlerin oder den kanzler
gestellt aber sie saßen eben mit dabei
und entschieden wurde neben
rentenpolitische sozialpolitische und
andere vorhaben und es wurde eben nicht
investiert in die dinge die sie jetzt
beklagen die abgesehen davon in sachen
schulen auch noch ländersache sind und
sie hat millionen in afghanistan
abgefackelt muss man auch mal sagen
hallo zusammen haben wir zusammenhang
ein seiner schweren bremse herlind nennt
so dass wir das klar haben markus söder
eröffnet da ich will dieses zitat ich
kann das rausholen also er formuliert
dass man es verfassung so der wirt die
tür geöffnet sagen sie die
schuldenbremse müssen wir einhalten die
hat verfassungsrang und wird ihn
behalten oder sagen sie auch und so sind
sie interpretiert worden zu beginn
dieses turnarounds brauchen wir ist ein
defizit für entlastungen und
investitionen unvermeidlich und ein
defizit ist gelesen wurden als mehr
schulden machen sie so interpretiert
werden nein möchte ich nicht es gibt ja
ein unterschied zwischen einem
ausgeglichenen haushalt ohne schulden
die so genannte schwarze null und
schuldenbremse hat sie nun
schuldenbremse erlaubt im verlauf der
wirtschaftlichen entwicklung auch die
aufnahme von krediten und das auch
sinnvoll das zu tun und deshalb die
leitplanke ist die schuldenbremse und
ich warne davor sie aufzuweichen wir
haben jetzt gegen werden niedrige zinsen
die amerikanische notenbank ist bereits
dabei ihre politik zu prüfen aufgrund
der inflation er wir können sehr schnell
eine situation geraten wo sich auch die
zinsen in europa verändern und dann
fliegen sehr schnell volkswirtschaften
die überschuldet sind aus der kurve wir
sollten anwalt von solidität sein ein
aufweichen der schuldenbremse bei uns
könnte eine fatale symbolwirkung auf
europa und jetzt kommen wir auf die
berechtigten anliegen von frau s können
die aber auch alle parteien
sie haben in ihrer aufzählung die
bundeswehr vergessen aber bei bildung da
kann der bund durchaus unterstützen bei
bildung öffentlicher infrastruktur auch
in der riesige investition so ist es und
hier ist doch der weg gerade von ihnen
aufgezeigt worden wir müssen innerhalb
des öffentlichen haushaltes prüfen wo
gibt es subventionen und ausgaben also
staatskonsum bei ihr wort was wir um
widmen können in den investiven bereich
warum denken wir nur in der ausdehnung
des budgets durch höhere steuern oder
durch höhere schulden warum denken wir
nicht innerhalb auch einmal des budgets
des staates daran dass man natürlich
auch umschichten kann man kann auch
sagen bestimmte ausgaben haben für uns
keine priorität mehr aber was wäre es
zum beispiel was würden sie nicht mehr
sehr gespannt was werden sie streichen
ich bin wenn ich das bin gegen eine
subvention für
elektro dienstwagen für gutverdiener wie
viel kondition mehrere mehrere
milliarden euro ist nur ein beispiel mal
die schulen wären froh sie hätten dieses
geld zusätzlich im übrigen wird wer auch
immer zu künftiger finanzminister sein
wird öfter das wort nein sagen müssen
zum beispiel nein zu einer milliarde
euro subvention für lasten fahrräder
okay die grünen jetzt gefordert da haben
wir auch schon dann gucken wir uns
vielleicht noch mal an der linde der
werden sie vielleicht auch gleich sagen
das stimmt nicht was sie tatsächlich in
ihrem wahlprogramm geschrieben haben wen
sie entlasten möchten wenn sie entlasten
und das gucken wir uns im vergleich mit
der spd mal an und diskutieren gleich
weiter familie 12 kinder bruttoeinkommen
40.000 euro bei der spd hätte diese
familie künftig etwa 4000 euro mehr im
jahr ginge es nach der fdp nur etwa 870
familie 22 kinder 300.000 euro brutto im
jahr bei der spd hätte diese familie
künftig etwa 13.000 euro weniger zur
verfügung bei der fdp rund 18.000 euro
mehr keine partei will den reichen mehr
schenken als die fdp
gleiches institut zb nachzulesen in ich
weiß nicht wer könnte aussuchen und
belegen glauben sie wenn der staat sich
verschuldete lindner dass man dann
ausgerechnet
den menschen die in dieser krise sogar
reichtum gewonnen haben reicher geworden
sind jetzt noch den soli schenken muss
irgendwie kämpfen muss gegen eine
vermögensabgabe gegen der
erbschaftssteuer könnten die reichen
nicht mehr geben
diese studie vom zaw sehe ich nicht als
eine seriöse gesprächsgrundlage warum
bei den geringverdienern ist bei der spd
berücksichtigt die erhöhung des
mindestlohns auf 12 euro das ist aber
keine steuerentlastung das zahlt gar
nicht der staat das zahlen
arbeitgeberinnen und arbeitgeber
wie kann das in eine solche studie
aufgenommen werden wo es um
steuerpolitik und sie wissen wie die
hunde von denen auf funk zu müssen die
untersten euro und bei unnützen design
schreibens ist unser liberales
bürgergeld zb in der gleichen
einkommensgruppe nicht berücksichtigt
deshalb auf der grundlage dieser zb
studie und dieser zahlen möchte ich
nicht diskutieren aber ich komme auf
ihre fragen bekommen wird warum hat man
der frage können die superreichen und
reichen die sogar in der krise kommen
uns haben ja ich komme jetzt auf ihre
ihre frage ich finde das wort etwas
schenken zum beispiel den
solidaritätszuschlag schenken wenn es um
steuerentlastungen geht finde ich nicht
angemessen es handelt sich um menschen
die verantwortung für arbeitsplätze
tragen es sind menschen die von deren
leistung wir sehr profitieren
ingenieurin und chefärzte beispielsweise
und insofern plattform zu schenken zu
sprechen halte ich für falsch und darum
geht es weder steuererhöhungen noch
steuerentlastung dürfen selbstzweck sein
sondern es geht ja immer um einen
höheren zweck und wenn wir sagen wir
wollen entlasten dann handelt es sich
zum beispiel um den selbständigen
handwerksmeister der aus seinem
einkommen sie haben das gerade hier
gezeigt aus seinem einkommen auch
ausbildungsplätze bezahlen muss weil die
einkommenssteuer bekanntlich für diese
betriebe in der regel auch die
betriebliche steuer ist die sind keine
gmbh die sind einzelunternehmer da
müssen arbeitsplätze geschaffen werden
die investition in den 3d drucker wird
von da bezahlt und im übrigen sage es
noch einmal bezahlt der
solidaritätszuschlag bitte darauf
gezahlt da kann der einkommensteuer
einkommensteuer bezahlt und auf das was
er nicht ist aber entschuldigt nicht in
die abrechnung straub kollegin es kann
aber selbstverständlich bei einer
investition wird die aus dem einkommen
finanziert und erst über mehrere jahre
wird die investition abgeschrieben das
heißt der hohe steuern zahlt hat weniger
liquidität bitte das noch mal genau
anschaut
die ausbildung lernen wenn das wir
einnehmen wenn die einkommen schon
abgeschrieben die einkommensteuer die
betriebliche steuer ist dann läuft der
gesamte aufwand dahin und das sind doch
gerade die betriebe die während der
krise zum teil an eigenkapital verloren
haben ich war heute abend beispielsweise
hier in berlin bei einer veranstaltung
eines einzelhändlers der hat zwar hilfen
bekommen aber trotzdem massiv
eigenkapital verloren und genau dem
kündigt die spd jetzt an ihn belasten zu
wollen und ich sage diesen mittelstand
den möchte ich im zweifel entlasten
damit auch die nächste krise überleben
kann so und jetzt trotzdem noch mal die
frage herr steigert es gibt menschen die
haben in dieser krise gewonnen und sie
haben sogar sehr viel gewonnen und sie
bieten manchmal von selbst an dass sie
höhere steuern zahlen würden so
millionäre und milliardäre gibt es oxfam
hat auch einen großen aufruf gestartet
dass man wenigstens eine einmalige
spende erfragt bei den menschen die
diese nicht viel geld verdienen warum
wird darüber nicht nachgedacht warum ist
es warum sollte das nicht auch sein und
würde wachstum aufhalten also ich würde
nicht sagen dass es ist großzügig wenn
leute das tun und diese spenden dieser
superreichen ja das können sie ja tun
aus meiner sicht die können spenden und
nicht wird auch nicht sagen dass wir in
einem land leben wo sozusagen da oben
armut herrscht darauf können wir uns
verständigen dass ein oberhalb von 2
300.000 euro herrscht keine armut aber
es ist schwierig tatsächlich das zu
sagen aber wenn das alles helfen würde
also wir decken die mieten und wir
verstaatlichen und wir rasieren oberhalb
von 150000 die leute einfach mal so
richtig und machen richtig mal tabula
rasa bei den reichen und bei den
immobilienbesitzern das würde dem land
und das ist auch ein teil der antwort
nichts nützen und das nicht wir müssen
aufwärts mobilität entwickeln wir müssen
kräfte entfalten wo leute bock haben
auch reich werden zu wollen wo leute
lust haben ein risiko einzugehen und
dann verdient man vielleicht auch mal
300.000 der der selbstständig aber ich
kenne auch selbstständigen das wissen
sie auch wer es genau geht es mindestens
noch mal keinen bock auf frau aufs reich
wie ja okay dann haben sie können das
immer sie können noch immer sozusagen
polemisch sagen jetzt redet jetzt nicht
für die managerin will das land die da
oben hast du diesen das land wohl nicht
ein mehr an staat braucht nach der über
griffigkeit in dieser pandemie und
danach hat sich was entwickelt ich
glaube wir brauchen im moment ein
weniger staaten stück mehr freiheit und
ein stück mehr innovation und
inspiration dann ist hier die frage zu
argumentieren genau dagegen
olaf scholz sagte das programm der cdu
sei unmoralisch glauben sie das was die
fdp vorschlägt frau sg ist unmoralisch
und erst die stimmen mit mit moral mit
kategorien der moral müssen wir da gar
nicht argumentieren sondern wir müssen
auch lage was ist was ist zielgerichtet
und zielgerichtet ist es ganz klar die
kleinen und mittleren einkommen erstens
zu entlasten und zweitens zu erhöhen
nämlich durch einen höheren mindestlohn
und auch durch flächendeckende
tarifverträge damit die leute wieder
ordentlich verdienen und aber mehr
bildung und mehr
beschäftigten vielmehr helfen vorweisen
nein das ist nicht richtig frei da also
davon gehen ja die löhne nicht hoch die
löhne eines einzelnen der mehr mehr
bildung der aufsteiger nur bildung
garage aufstieg doch nicht der staat
aber aber herr steingart die die jobs
die da schlecht bezahlt sind in die wir
besser bezahlen wir wollen die müssen ja
denn die noch gemacht werden wenn ihr
jetzt alle aufsteiger ich habe schon mal
wir haben schon mal gesprochen wenn er
jetzt alle paketboten die grenzstation
übernehmen wer bringt ihnen denn dann
ihre patienten die leute sollen
anständig bezahlt werden sollen ohne
stütze vom staat ihre familien versorgen
können und dann können die auch
tatsächlich sich freischwimmen das ist
und sagen mindestlohn weg - und dann
wird alles gut aber dann
aber sie leben die gleichen aus meiner
sicht der kleine aufstiegs panja
natürlich der galerie b note soll auch
in meiner sicht nicht narkotisiert
werden mit dem mindestlohn und davon
immer paket ohne bleibt ohne aber die
drohne wahrheit liegt irgendwo
dazwischen ist ja weder so oder
so das ist bei den spitzenverdienern nur
um diesen handwerksmeister geht den
hellen sozusagen immer vor sich herträgt
aber es ist auch nicht so dass die
steuererhöhungspläne der spd jetzt nur
die wirklich aller obersten 5000
erreichen man muss sich auch einfach mal
klar machen
was was das leben kostet welche abgaben
welche eine vierköpfige familie mit zwei
berufstätigen
akademikern können sich aus eigener
kraft in den teuren städten keine
eigentumswohnungen mehr kaufen ohne dass
sie geerbt haben und da muss man sich
einfach auch mal klar machen die nicht
abschaffung des solis die trifft
natürlich nur einen gewissen teil aber
erstens ist es aufkommt weil sie die
hälfte noch erhalten geblieben da finde
ich kann man nicht von der abschaffung
sprechen es ist doch klar dass natürlich
der verdienst hat natürlich dann
entsprechend auch mehr steuern und wird
dann auch mehr entlastet das ist aber
nicht per se und moralisch sie treffen
natürlich jetzt nicht nur die
einkommensmillionäre sondern natürlich
geht es auch um gutverdiener ja
natürlich verdienen die gut aber das ist
auch nicht per se sozusagen erstmal ein
problem und das muss man dann schon auch
ehrlich sagen es ist weder so dass es
nun den mittelstand geht noch ist es so
dass es nun die einkommensmillionäre
die erhöhung da oben an der spitze will
ich jetzt noch mal sagen dort ist es
auch kein rasieren sondern wirklich ein
sehr bescheidener betrag ist
ich kenne ja wie helmut schmidt wähler
verloren mit dieser art politik haben
sie die helmut schmidt wähler aus den
70er jahren verloren sie sind zu weit
gegangen sie sind zu weit in die mitte
gegangen mit ihrer steuerpolitik und
haben ihre ehemalige klientel an wen
auch immer verloren man muss vielleicht
noch eine eine sogar ganz kurze sekunde
eine frage noch mal direkt das argument
von von rosbach aufgreifend wenn wir
sehen dass die dass die energiepreise
steigen dass die mieten steigen dass die
sozialbeiträge steigen dass die
inflation kommt ist das leben der den
schuss noch nicht also die oder schon da
es ist das leben nicht auch ohne
steuererhöhungen teurer geworden die
sozialbeiträge sind nicht gestiegen
sondern wir haben sie stabilisiert wir
haben auch gerade beim beim
krankenkassenbeitrag wieder die parität
hergestellten nicht etwas
armenien haben dazu geführt dass die
rentenbeiträge nicht gesunken sind das
ist die haltelinie beim beitrag gewesen
bislang
können können auch derzeit nicht sinken
dazu müssten wir wesentlich mehr in die
rente einbeziehen damit denn damit diese
können aber wir hätten ein bisschen
durcheinander als die sozialbeiträge
sind nicht gestiegen die mieten steigen
ins unermessliche
dann müssen wir zwei einheiten dann
müssen wir zum einen wesentlich mehr
bauen vor allem auch natürlich in
sozialbindung bauen damit wieder
bezahlbarer wohnraum auch entsteht das
falten fällt ja derzeit mehr aus der
sozialbindung heraus als dass wir
zusätzlich bauen 400.000 wohnungen pro
jahr zusätzlich zu bauen und 100.000
davon mit öffentlicher förderung wenn es
ganz klare plans skg pfizer und es daher
nicht koalieren will in berlin mit
jemandem der enteignungen fordert ist es
in ordnung in ihren
wir machen jetzt hier kann der berliner
landespolitik sondern wir machen bundes
oder nein also soll enteignet werden
dürfen ich glaube in einigen sind ein
teil in unseres grundgesetzes sind
verankert in der verfassung
werden sie regelmäßig auch angewandt von
herrn steuer zum beispiel
wenn gewalt eigentum ist nicht von
aggressiven aber sie wissen sie wissen
sie wissen sehr genau dass in unserem
zukunftsprogramm von enteignungen in
diesem zusammenhang mit wohnungsbau
nicht die rede ist sondern dass es darum
geht dass wir wesentlich mehr bauen
müssen und dass wir in der zeit wo die
wohnungen fehlen wo wir hochangespannte
mietmärkte ja auch haben in stetten dass
wir dort auch morath und moratorium
ermöglichen wollen das sind die beiden
instrumente zusätzlich neue wohnung
wurden eigentums genossenschaften zu
ermöglichen und gemeinnützigkeit damit
etwas vorwärts also was ich nicht will
ich in bezug auf die hmi von dem sie
wissen ja moment wenn es um die
energiepreise geht dann haben wir ganz
klar gesagt
werden wir nicht schaffen sie hat aber
seine vor mir sah es noch wie sie es
lesen umlage abschaffen bitte jetzt
nicht das ganze programm wir haben ein
thema beim thema steuern und soziale hat
danach gefragt japan aber nicht
insgesamt teur ich mir ist nur ein punkt
wichtig wir haben in deutschland bereits
umverteilung at its best denn man sieht
dass 50 prozent der
einkommensteuerzahler 90 prozent des
aufkommens leisten und ich wundere mich
frei es können warum sie sich nicht als
sozialdemokratie sehr viel stärker
konzentrieren auf die menschen mit ganz
kleinem einkommen die sich mit fleiß
nach oben arbeiten wollen und da hätte
ich für sie vorschläge sie wollen den
mindestlohn erhöhen aber wenn sie die
minijob grenze nicht erhöhen und die
allermeisten menschen die mindestlohn
beziehen arbeiten in einem minijob dann
haben die menschen gar nicht mehr
einkommen sondern sie haben einfach die
minijob grenze die arbeiten weniger
stunden haben aber nicht mehr netto und
ich frage mich warum sie sich nicht an
die alge 2 an die hartz4 empfänger
wenden da gibt es viele die neben hartz4
arbeiten und wer da ein 450 euro job hat
der zahlt ab 100 euro die sind außen vor
80 prozent von seinem einkommen gibt der
höchsten der hessen gleich eine höchste
quasi steuersatz in deutschland ist
ausgerechnet bei den hartz 4 empfängern
die arbeiten weil die der lage gerechnet
das wäre gerechtigkeit da zeigt sich auf
dem areal wo ist auch sozial wenn man
nämlich sagt wer arbeitet muss mehr
haben als der der nicht arbeitet nochmal
hartz4 das ist in der spd natürlich mit
großem schmerz empfunden sie wollen sich
das nicht nur von den hartz-reformen
sondern es ist in teilen schon geschehen
was kann man tun für die menschen die
prekär beschäftigt mit mini jobs in
diesen schlechten teams
zunächst mal auch nicht jeder
mindestlöhne arbeitet im minijob ganz
bestimmt nicht ich kenne eine ganze
menge menschen die als produktionshelfer
in der produktion arbeiten vollzeit dem
mindestlohn arbeiten und dann aufstocken
um ihre familie über wasser zu halten
und das ist kein zustand wir
subventionieren löhne und das ist nicht
in ordnung und deswegen muss der
minister auf wenigstens zwölf euro
erhöht werden damit die leute auch in
würde dafür bezahlt werden da sie
vollzeit arbeiten und ihr leben
bewältigen und die sollen nicht nebenher
noch ein mini job machen müssen um sich
einigermaßen über wasser zu halten das
ist nicht in ordnung das ist unanständig
wir hatten schon mal darüber gesprochen
eine dreiköpfige familie also drei
kinder zwei erwachsene einer arbeitet
mehr wie ist da der anspruch an
lohnersatzleistungen aus dem harz 4
system wie hoch müsste der mindestlohn
seien damit da wenn nur einer arbeitet
nicht aufgestockt so einen mindestlohn
nicht mal die linke jetzt lassen wir mal
nicht das wohngeld weg wo die leute dann
darauf anspruch haben und oft auch audi
die kindergrundsicherung die wir ja auch
ganz klar in unserem neuen sozialstaats
konzept aufgezeigt habe müssen
wir müssen lernen menschen qualifiziert
sind ganz viele menschen gar nicht
staatliche unterstützung die wollen
aufsteigen die durch arbeit kinder
wollen qualifikation haben wir wollen
dann einen job haben der gut bezahlten
erstmal eine unterstützung damit sie
überhaupt die besten chancen auch eltern
ja wie lange weil sie dem vereinigen
brauchen die eltern einen guten job und
die waren immer was für reiche klientel
sind wir sind schon fast am ende dieser
sendung und könnten sagen dass wir in
den ziemlichen bogen geschlagen haben
frau sie denken wenn sie an den 26 9
denken
welchen kategorien politisch was glauben
sie bräuchte dieses land inhaltlich und
politisch am ehesten um aus dieser
gefühlten und der de facto krise
herauszukommen gewünschte koalition und
realistische koalition
ich glaube die beiden realistischen
koalitionen werden entweder jamaika oder
ampel je nachdem ob union oder spd vorn
liegen wahrscheinlich werden beide dann
rechnerisch möglich aber wenn drei
parteien gewonnen und eines verloren hat
dann ist natürlich eigentlich auf der
hand liegend wäre sozusagen erst mal
versucht eine regierung zu bilden
es ist in jedem fall gut dass es nicht
nochmal eine große koalition gibt das
war letztes mal schon sehr ermüdend dass
man sich das noch mal vier jahre
anschauen musste bislang hat jede
regierung der vergangenen jahre nur das
geld zusammengehalten mann kam immer
dann zusammen indem man sagt ja du
möchtest du möchtest b na gut dann
machen wir beide läuferinnen zu uns
leisten und was dabei herausgekommen ist
ist jetzt nicht das konsistente zukunfts
und innovationsprogramm dass man
gebraucht hätte und es wäre sehr schön
wenn man da einfach eine klarere linie
hätte wo dieses land hin soll gabor
steingart lieblingskoalition aus welchem
inhaltlichen grund und realistische am
26.9
also im moment nicht olaf scholz vorn
ich glaube dass trotzdem nur eine
momentaufnahme
das land ist die hoffen noch auf ich
hoffe ich bin beobachter ich denke dass
das das volk ist vernünftiger als man
vielleicht gemeinhin denkt aber nicht
dass das volk mehr links koalition
derzeit will ich weiß allerdings auch
aus kenntnis der person des olaf scholz
dass man sich über ökonomie weiß auch
weiß der weiß auch das was der armin
laschet auch was insofern hoffe ich dass
genau wie gerd schröder der ja nicht mit
der agenda 2010 in das wahljahr gezogen
ist am ende nicht links und rechts
sondern was vernünftiges gemacht wird
unabhängig davon wer die beteiligten
figuren sind nach den letzten zehn
jahren merkel muss ein stück
modernisierung stattfinden dass davon
bin ich überzeugt und ich glaube dass
das auch scholz weiß die raute ist ist
für mich ein augenzwinkern fast ein
nostalgischer gruß an die als kanzlerin
und er muss wissen und er weiß es auch
oder ich mein eindruck ist dass die
politiker mit denen ich spreche es auch
im übrigen die wissen alle dass wir mit
mindestlohn allein und mit
lohnersatzleistungen das land nicht
flott kriegen oder dann machen wir sie
nicht noch nicht aber es muss ja auch
nicht sein wir können das einfach so
stehen lassen und machen einen punkt an
dieser stelle ich darf mich bei den vier
gästen heute abend sehr herzlich
bedanken gebe es sofort zu markus lanz
über